alors dans la vie il ya ceux qui disent
qu'ils peuvent et ceux qui disent qu'ils
ne peuvent pas je suis marie burlot j'ai
21 ans et cela fait cinq ans que j'ai
créé ma première société on est alors le
28 novembre 2009 quand ma vie est sur le
point de prendre un nouveau tournant
moi à l'époque j'étais j'avais
mes 15 ans j'étais pas dans l'idée de
créer une société si jeune moi j'étais
une ado comme tout le monde qui s'en
était un peu en dehors des courts et en
dehors en dehors de ces cours je
je je excusez moi et j'essaie donc
j'avais j'avais mes 15 ans j'étais une
ado qui en dehors des cours ne faisait
pas grand chose et comme ceux de mon âge
bas j'avais je m'engage était à la
campagne et j'avais des animaux pour
m'occuper à l'époque moi je devais avoir
un chien un chat de lapin un alpaga et
un furet et c'est ce dernier qui me
demandait le plus de temps pour
m'occuper parce qu'en dehors du fait
qu'il dorme 20 heures par jour eh bien
les quatre heures d'éveil restantes
elles étaient plutôt bien rempli alors
pour vous dire aussi sur cet animal il
est plutôt douillet parce que quand on
passe 80 % de son temps à dormir c'est
vrai qu on peut avoir quelques exigences
sur son sommeil et le must have que se
doivent avoir tous propriétaires du
furet
c'est un hamac pas pour soi pour le
furet alors vous inquiétez pas je suis
pas là pour vous faire un cours sur
l'animal moi je vais revenir au niveau
de l'ado qui ne fait rien de sa vie
parce que en dehors des quand on est
jeune et qu'on s'ennuie à la campagne
heureusement on a d'autres sources de
distraction que les animaux et notamment
internet on peut passer des heures à
surfer sur le web pour découvrir des
choses qui la plupart du temps ne
servent à rien il faut le dire mais
parfois on découvre des choses qui
peuvent être intéressantes et même très
intéressant dirait alors est ce qu'il ya
des gens dans la salle qui ont des ados
ce que vous ok alors écoutez bien ce qui
suit parce que je parle au nom de mes
parents mais il se pourrait bien qu'un
jour votre ado vous donne rendez vous
dans votre propre maison
pour vous faire une annonce
il ou elle pourrait bien tourner autour
du pot pendant une bonne demi-heure je
dirais avant de vous dire qu'il a une
idée géniale et que ça implique de créer
une entreprise
et la boum la première nouvelle est
tombée votre bébé a grandi
normalement à partir de là vous devez
commencer à écouter un petit peu plus
attentivement ce qu'il a raconté
d'autant que ça ne va pas s'arranger
parce qu'en soi va créer une entreprise
à 15 ans si c'est pour vendre de la
limonade vote comme peut voir dans les
séries ou les films à notre âge bah ça
ne mange pas de pain mais quand on vous
dit que les principaux clients de cette
entreprise seront des furets et voilà je
vous dis que ça coince un peu ici et moi
mes pauvres parents à l'époque j'avoue
que je leur aurais dit que j'étais
tombée enceinte je pense qu'ils se
seraient tout autant demander quelle est
l épisode manquant le quai ce qui se
passait et c'est précisément à ce moment
que j'ai choisi de dégainer les cartes
de visite l'époque est le mini business
plan pour les achever parce que je leur
ai montré que le furet c'était le
troisième animal de compagnie en france
et aux états unis avec près de 9
millions de personnes d'animaux sur les
zones de france et d'amérique et ce en
passant les détails je leur ai démontré
par a plus b que j'avais découvert un
business au poil c'est le cas de le dire
sur un marché de niche encore peu
exploité mais avec une vraie demande
et donc comme je l'aï dit au début faut
quand même se recentrer à mes 15 ans
j'étais pas forcément envie de créer une
entreprise mais là j'avais un marché qui
s'imposait à moi et en plus l'un des
seuls dans lequel je pouvais avoir une
certaine légitimité
même sans le bac puisque j'avais cet
animal depuis mai 11 ans et que je
connaissais par coeur les problèmes
rencontrés par leurs propriétaires
alors donc suite à l'annoncé un peu de
tonitruantes que j'ai fait à mes parents
donc ils ont un peu réfléchi et ils sont
revenus un jour vers moi en me disant
vas qu' il allait me laisser ma chance
et maintenant qu'on en reparle
aujourd'hui bas ils me disent que à vrai
dire au moment où ils ont pris cette
décision il pensait que ça me mènerait
pas forcément bien loin eric ce serait
surtout une bonne expérience
oui ils connaissaient pas encore bien
leur progéniture mais ça il ne sait pas
encore alors du coup je me suis dépêché
et après leur avoir promis que je
mènerai plus d'études de marché secrète
comme celle ci est bien jaugé crée donc
une marque d'accessoires pour furets
et j'ai mis un an donc de mes 15 ans
avait 16 ans à peu près à monter cette
marque
faut savoir donc j'ai pas cherché non
plus la facilité de dents puisque
il fallait en fait j'aurais pu acheter
des accessoires en chine ou je ne sais
où autres mais moi j'ai voulu créer une
marque avec des valeurs qui me tenait à
coeur comme le made in france donc à ce
moment là je me suis plutôt rendu compte
qu'il était plus facile de trouver des
partenaires au maroc qu'en france mais
j'étais têtue et je vais chercher
chercher jusqu'à arriver à la vision je
m'étais fait de cette entreprise d
accessoires donc de qualité française
est confectionnée par des couturières en
situation de handicap
donc suite à ça j'ai pu enfin lancer
cette société féret dream et débuter
cette aventure qui m'amènerait bien plus
loin que je ne l'aurais imaginé
alors dans cette aventure justement j'ai
très certainement été influencé par mes
parents qui sont eux mêmes entrepreneurs
et que j'ai toujours vu travailler
d'arrache-pied
il y à mon père qui est parti de rien et
qui aujourd'hui récolte des fruits de ce
qu'il a semé et ma mère qui l'a rejoint
dans cette entreprise et qui a été une
force incroyable pour maintenir l'équipe
de votre famille tout en s'investissant
à ses côtés
alors ses parents je les ai vus trimer
tomber parfois et même perdre pied entre
le travail et la vie donc contrairement
à ce qu'on peut penser j'aurais pu
facilement être dégoûté par
l'entrepreneuriat quand je voyais tout
ce que tous les efforts qu'il fallait
faire pour réussir
et ce d'autant plus qu'à l'époque
j'avais commencé à monter mes propres
projets d'avenir mon rêve est en touche
et l'excellence et ça se matérialisait
par l'entrée hec mais justement je
voudrais peut-être faire un point là
dessus parce que je suis tombé dedans et
je pense que le problème de certains
jeunes aujourd'hui cette visée une école
plus qu'un métier et d'obtenir un
diplôme plus que des compétences moi à
ce moment là ma voix au niveau scolaire
elle était toute tracée et c'est
l'entrepreneuriat qui est venu
chambouler tout ça
parce qu'entre prendre c'est
effectivement créé suivre son propre
chemin et moi quand je regarde en
arrière je vois bien que le mien il n'a
jamais été comme les autres j'ai
toujours cherché à me différencier pour
me démarquer et quand on sort du cadre
baa les réactions elles sont jamais en
demi teinte
tous n'ont pas compris pourquoi est ce
que je voulais entreprendre si jeune et
de mes proches à des inconnus les
réactions ça pouvait aller du gentil bon
faut pas qu'un métro comme toi parce que
sinon il n'y a plus de place pour les
adultes à des choses déjà plus mesquine
comme me disant que je devais plutôt
être une femme et un furet déguisé en
femme pour avoir ce type d'idées et j'ai
même reçu des mails m'accusant de
participer à la faim dans le monde en
vendant ses accessoires sans commentaire
en tout cas beaucoup m'ont dit que je
m'engageais sur une voie dangereuse pour
mes études moi qui avait tant de
potentiel il estimait voilà que créer
une entreprise ats cet âge c'était pas
raisonnable et que je m'embêtais du
travail en plus alors j'aurais pu
simplement profiter de ma jeunesse
mais ça veut dire quoi profiter de sa
jeunesse parce que si ça consiste à se
mettre la tête à l'envers toutes les
semaines et à prester le reste de son
temps à poster des selphy sur les
réseaux sociaux ou à jouer à des jeux en
ligne bah c'est franchement réducteur
pour l'ensemble des jeunes
vous avez vous avez
sur les ces jeunes ils ont souvent peur
de ce qui les attend et moi en premier
et c'est vrai que quand on parle
d'entrepreneuriat en plus on se jette
littéralement dans l'inconnu
or
ce qui peut faire c'est ça qui va pas
faire peur au point de paralyser les
jeunes donc de ne pas être dans l'action
les incompréhensions généralement c'est
parce que on ne sait pas ou qu'est ce
qu'on va légitime qu'est ce qu'il va
conscience bouge les fesses qu'est ce
qu'on va apprendre qu'est ce qu'on va
avoir sans parler forcément de
récompenses pécuniaires en échange de ce
travail
la réalité c'est que nous quand on est
jeune et bien on n'en sait rien on n'en
sait rien et moi je me dis que quand on
dit qu'on est jeune et qu'on doit pas
entreprendre parce qu'il ya des études
il ya ce genre de choses eh bien je
regarde ces chanteurs à la télé qui ont
14 15 16 ans et je me dis pourquoi est
ce qu'on ne leur dit pas votre vous
allez gâcher votre jeunesse vous allez
oublier des choses dans votre vie et
pourquoi du coup je pense pas qu'on le
leur dise et pourquoi est ce qu on le
dirait un jeune entrepreneur et pourquoi
est-ce qu'on me le dis à moi
parce que l'entrepreneuriat
effectivement ça fait grandir plus vite
mais c'est aussi ce qui permet moi de me
réaliser et de vivre des choses que
d'autres jeunes n'ont peut-être pas
encore vécu
parce que être un jeune entrepreneur ce
n'est pas être une victime c'est être le
capitaine comme le capitaine d'un bateau
qui peut prendre un cap différent des
autres mais arrivait plus également à la
ddt sur la destination alors rien dit
qu'entre temps il ne fera pas le remake
du titanic parce que
tout le monde peut faire des erreurs et
je vais m'arrêter là parce qu'après il
ya des morts dans l'histoire est que la
thème d'aujourd'hui ses gammes les
jolies choses mais en tous les cas ce
qui fera alors son succès ou son échec
c'est sa capacité à se relever à
apprendre et à se remettre de ses
erreurs des choses qu'on apprend souvent
bien plus tard mais qui peuvent faire la
différence dans une vie
moi ce que je tiens à dire à tous ces
jeunes c'est qu'aujourd'hui le monde
leur est ouvert parce que malgré malgré
ce qu'on dit moi dans mes rencontres
effectivement j'ai été victime de
discrimination mais je veux parler d'une
discrimination positive à mon égard
parce que tous ces professionnels qui
dont j'avais tellement peur à 16 ans
j'en avais mal au ventre à la seule idée
de décrocher le téléphone et bien et
n'ont jamais cherché à profiter de mon
âge ni mon statut de débutante mais bien
au contraire ils ont cherché à valoriser
mon esprit d'initiative et on a
fonctionné très rapidement dans une
relation de respect les uns avec les
autres alors
j'aimerais dire à tous ceux qui ont des
rêves ou des idées et qui ont peur
d'entreprendre ou non et bien que le
la chose à retenir c'est que ce qui ne
compte pas c'est pas où on est
aujourd'hui mais où on veut être demain
et donc de
la peur de ne pas avoir peur du
changement parce que la plus grande le
plus grand obstacle j'ai jamais eu à
affronter c'était moi même
alors
le haut niveau du haut niveau de ces
mois pour vous donner un exemple très
concret
g j'ai commencé quand j'étais donc à 16
ans j'ai pu rencontrer une femme dont
côte de turin qui était la fondatrice
d'un plus d'un des plus grands forums
d'influencé internationale
dans le monde
ensuite je suis rentré à l'essec avant
même d'avoir eu mon bac et j'ai
également j'ai également été plus jeunes
délégués mondiale au g20 yes un sommet
international sur trois jours qui donc
faisait se rassembler 400 entrepreneurs
emblématiques pour
émettre une série de propositions sur
l'entrepreneuriat donc tout ça pour vous
dire qu'on ne réussit pas par chance
mais par choix et que les occasions
elles se multiplient quand on sait les
saisir
là par exemple toujours pour vous donner
un exemple très concret il ya je lance
un second projet est il ya quelques
temps j'ai pas peur de le dire j'avais
une période de doute
et dans ces cas là je vais entre autres
justement sur internet pour le soin et
lire des textes ou écouter des motifs
des vidéos motivante et c'est dans ce
cadre là que j'ai je connais cette aide
mais aux états unis et je me disais que
ces grands orateurs qui avaient la
possibilité de me rebooster en quelques
minutes et ben si un jour j'avais la
possible de faire leur côté ce serait
une vraie satisfaction personnelle et
devinez quoi quelques temps plus tard
j'ai reçu ce coup de fil qui fait que je
suis devant vous aujourd'hui
alors certains me diront que j'ai
peut-être une bonne étoile oui sans
doute mais je sais aussi créer ma chance
parce que là par exemple à chaque fois
je dois parler en public j'ai peur
j'étais comme ça avant d'entrer et c'est
précisément à chaque fois que j'ai cette
peur que je me force à me dépasser
ça c'est sans doute d'un des plus grands
acquis que m'a appris l'entrepreneuriat
c'est que hand quand
la seule constante dans ce monde si vous
laissez le changement et le changement
ce n'est pas confortable
alors
si si dans ce monde vous n'êtes pas vous
devez pouvoir vous adapter et moi quand
je dois affronter un obstacle je me
projette toujours positivement en train
de surmonter par exemple moi donc comme
j'habite à la campagne comme je vous le
disais je me dis que tous ces grands
chênes qui sont autour de moi bah un
jour ou l'autre ils ont d'abord été un
gland comme ça aussi puissant et
majestueux soit il
alors moi aussi j'ai les capacités on a
tous des ressources qu'on mobilise plus
ou moins différemment et efficacement
mais ce qui ce qu'il faut dire
aujourd'hui c'est que on ne pensera
jamais
dans la stade de parfaite confiance en
soi en son projet ou en ses équipes si
on écoute un petit peu les personnes qui
ont réussi dans ce monde généralement
elles ont
elles sont toujours vécu des échecs mais
ses échecs elles les ont transformés en
erreur puisque elles ont su tirer les
leçons qu'il y avait à apprendre de ces
et de ses erreurs de ses échecs donc
voilà il n'ya pas il ya peu de chose qui
mérite qu'on en ait peur dans cette vie
et la chose ce qui en dehors de se dire
que voilà il faut se projeter dans un
parcours il faut s'ouvrir réussir à se
projeter dans une vie où l'on réussit en
tous les cas
qu importe votre âge où les choix ou la
vie que vous menez actuellement ce sont
vous avez toujours le choix parce que ce
ne sont pas nos actes qui définit ce qui
nous sommes mais nommer nos paroles
si
faut pas s'attendre en fait à arriver un
jour à un carrefour de sa vie et de voir
prendre cette décision parce que ça
n'arrivera pas
ça n'arrivera pas parce que ce sont ces
actes quotidiens qui vont définir le
chemin que nous prenons et c'est la
somme de ces choix qui peuvent paraître
en apparence anodins qui vont construire
notre personnalité et au final notre vie
alors en conclusion je dirais que bas
plutôt que d'attendre la révélation au
bout d'un chemin tout tracé
éteignez un petit peu votre gps interne
arrêtez de vous laisser guider en
automatique et prenez tous ces petits
détours sur votre propre voix parce
qu'au bout du chemin vous découvrirez
peut-être votre voix comme moi